oh hey what you got there
nothing nothing a blu-ray blu-ray disc
assistant blu-ray this system if you're
worth going to jail for that I'm $700
DVD player 700 oh man it did they drop
these down to like 250 to 69 right now
no oh yeah these jeepers hey now if I
watch blu-rays on my - is it gonna have
letterbox there's gonna be full frame
hey what you got there old blu-ray
player I play a new rule of a little way
plant I got a question
yeah those things play on plasmas are
just CRT no no display on plasma they
are team DLP this a LCD any kind of
format you hear how much you pay for
that one right there this one right here
yeah oh this looks free from the App
Store hey Junior yeah you still got that
8-track tape player yeah I don't think
those are work on a blu-ray